Music All Kids Podcast Podcast Ufo DPU-Podcast-UFO, natürlich wie immer, im Original, mit Stefan Tietze. Mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, aber auch dir. Und das sollte man nicht unterschätzen, deine Aufgabe hier, wo und hin will. Wir unterschätzen natürlich auch niemals die fantastischen Komponisten, die uns diese grandiosen Intros einschränken. Dieses Mal kommt das Intro von Albrecht. Albrecht, vielen Dank. Fantastisches Intro, vielen, vielen Dank. So, aber jetzt hier nicht mit Intro und bla bla bla und Begrüßungen drüber hinwegtäuschen, dass ich hier seit drei Stunden sitze, auf dich warte. Drei Stunden ist Quatsch. Ich weiß nicht, was nicht gefahren wird, weil der große Florentin Will hat sich erbarmt, noch mal zu mir zu Stoßen, um diese Podcast-Folge aufzunehmen. Also erst mal drei Stunden ist Quatsch, lass uns die Fakten erst mal richtig kriegen, drei Stunden ist erst mal Quatsch. Ich habe dir zwei Minuten vom ursprünglichen Termin geschrieben, es wird leicht später. Ja, das funktioniert schon nicht. Du kannst nicht zwei, das ist immer so, dann ist man fein raus. Ich weiß schon, ich kenne das selber, das Gewissen, was man selber hat, das schlechte Gewissen, befriedigt nicht so leicht, wenn man noch absagt und sagt, ich komme zu spät. Es bringt nur nichts, wenn es zwei Minuten vor dem fucking Termin ist, alle sind schon da. Regel, man muss so lang, wie man sich verspätet, vor dem eigentlichen Termin absagen. Das finde ich fantastisch. Wenn ich zwei Stunden zu spät komme, muss ich zwei Stunden vor dem vereinbarten Termin sagen, ich komme zwei Stunden später. Fantastische Regel. Ist das eine Regel? Können wir das so eintragen in die ... in die Puffopedia? Wir haben noch 20 Seiten übrig in der Puffopedia, wir haben noch ein bisschen Platz. In was trägt man solche gesellschaftlichen Gepflogenheiten ein? Weil es ist ja nicht alles in Stein gemeißelt, es ist auch nicht alles, es geht ja auch Dinge, passieren im Wandel der Zeit. Und jetzt gerade kann man zum Beispiel gut absagen, früher konnte man gar nicht absagen. Wie viele Menschen damals einfach rumstanden und drauf im Regen und bei Gewitter im Hintergrund John Williams spielt und weißt du, niemand kommt. Das ist auch traurig, mittlerweile kann man gut absagen. Ich glaube, sowas war halt mal der Knigge, wo halt solche Regeln drin waren. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so ein Buch oder ein Mensch oder irgendwas. Ja, das ist ein Buch. Das ist mein Fall. Einfach ein Buch und da muss man einfach was reinschreiben, dass man einfach sowas, der moderne Knigge. Aber ist das wie so ein Dittl-Buch, wo einfach jeder reinschreiben kann? Nee, ich glaube nicht, der durfte ursprünglich nur Knigge reinschreiben. Herr Knigge. Herr Knigge, das ist eigentlich auch ein cooler Club von diesen Leuten, die als Person völlig unbekannt sind, ihr Wirken aber bekannt ist, wie zum Beispiel der Fürst Pückler, der ein extrem menschenverachtendes Folterregime geführt hat, aber halt diese geile Eisschnitte erfunden hat. Aber diese Eisschnitte, diese süße, leckere Eisschnitte, diese Erdbeer-Schoko-Vanille, geile Kombination, Erdbeer-Schoko-Vanille ist ja heute selbstverständlich die Combo, bis dahin nicht. Die haben damals Pfirsich, Maracuja, Kaffee immer zusammen gegessen. Ab da war es einfach klar, dass du mit drei Fahnen. Aber ich finde gut, dass du schon wieder vom Thema ablecken willst. Du bist zu spät gekommen und ich frage mich langsam, bin ich das Problem oder hast du noch Bock auf das Projekt? Nein, ich bin das Problem und ich muss dir was sagen.
Ich habe heute was erlebt.
Was ist los?
Ich war auf Reisen, auf einer Odyssee und ich habe schon viele lebt in meinem Reiseleben.
Die Gleise sind meine Heimat, du weisst es, aber heute ist nochmal was passiert, das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt.
Ich sitze im Ruheabteil im Intercity Express, stell den Sitz zurück und Kopfhörer rein. Das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt. Und frag, was wollen Sie denn von mir? Er sagt, ihre Kopfhörer sind nicht verbunden und der ganze Zug hört Toy Story 4. So ne unfassbare Peinlichkeit wär für andere ein Graus. Aber ich, ich bin ein Podcaster und mach ne Anekdote draus, und das sind richtig gute, ich musste noch schnell einkaufen gehen. Doch mein Kopf war voll und die Bifi-Roll musste ich in meiner Tasche mitnehmen. An der Kasse werde ich rausgeholt, der Ladendetektiv nimmt mich mit. Doch was sind fünfhundert Euro und Hausverbot gegen dieses perfekte Bild? Richtig Gute. Das wird ne super Folge, richtig gut.
Gute zehn Minuten für unsere Fans im Internet,
gute zehn Minuten Comedy-Gold,
gute zehn Minuten für unsere Fans am End gerät.
Gute zehn Minuten sind das, was ihr erhaltet.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach, jede Woche zu killen.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach, sechzig Minuten zu füllen. Ein Podcast erleben heisst die Welt durchs Mikro zu sehen. Sich mit Stories umgeben, schlecht den Hut umzudrehen, an die Grenzen zu gehen. Meine Tante starb auf einer Segway-Tour, der Gag schreibt sich doch von allein. Menschenverachtende Diktaturen, was könnte jemals lustiger sein? Hier ist ein kleines Kind vor's Bus-at-Bord gerannt, das ist doch jetzt schon die perfekte Rubrik. Massenschlägerheit muss Phantasialand, das ist Comedy, Mathematik. Meine Freundin hat grad Schluss gemacht, ich sah ihr zu zynisch drauf. Das hat keine Gags hervorgebracht, was fällt dir ein, wir nehmen gleich auf. Und wir brauchen gute zehn Minuten für unsere Fans im Internet. Gute zehn Minuten Comedy-Ault, gute zehn Minuten und warum singen wir ein Lied? Gute zehn Minuten, bleibt das jetzt so? Gute zehn Minuten, kriegt man nicht jede Woche hin. Gute zehn Minuten, was macht man denn da?
Gute zehn Minuten, sind jemand anderem passiert?
Gute zehn Minuten, sind vielleicht gar nicht wahr?啊 Musik Ich komme zu spät, ich steh im Regen, wo bleibt die Bahn, ist das wirklich mein Leben? Ist das wirklich mein Leben, ist das wirklich mein Leben zwischen Goslar und Bad Gandersheim? Das kann's nicht sein.
Zum Glück bin ich nicht alleine hier, mein best Jeder Tag ist immer gleich, nur wegen Stefan und Florentin übersteh ich ihn. Ihre Geschichten sind in meinem Ohr und wenn mal Werbung kommt, dann spul ich halt vor. Neue gute zehn Minuten aus dem IC, unglaublich, was der ständig erlebt. Im Ufo ist immer ein Platz für mich, auch wenn das alte Intro fehlt. Ich hör mir jedes Mal die neue Folge an, ganz egal worum es geht, ich bleibe dran. Ich drück Play, er ist da, jedes Mal ein Spaß, mein bester Freund der Podcast. Holt mich aus dem grauen Leben raus, gebt mir immer Halt und baut mich auf, wo ich bin, ist er auch, immer wenn ich ihn brauch, mein bester Freund der Podcast und ich. Meine Schwester ruft mich an, ich frag mich, warum ich ihr Gelaber nicht einfach skippen kann. Und mein Kumpel mit seinem Krypto-Hype hat leider keine Funktion für Doft und Schwindigkeit. Ich hab lieber das Pufu um mich herum. Und wenn Antenne Afrika kommt, dann schalt ich halt um. Meine App ist von oben bis unten voll, ich höre Leila, Klaas und Böhmermann. Mark Merrin ist mega und Hazel ist toll, meine Freundesliste ist lang. Und ich hör mir jedes Mal die neue Folge an, ganz egal worum es geht, ich bleibe dran. Ich drück Play, er ist da, jedes Mal ein Spaß, mein bester Freund der Podcast. Mit Mordlust einen neuen Fall aufgenommen, mit den Tränis in der Comfortzone angekommen, Radio Nucula von immer da, immer da. Es sei denn, wie wurde gerade das Herz gebrochen, da hätt ich gerne mit einer echten Person gesprochen. Aber immer wieder geht eine Folge los, ich bin nicht allein und die Welt ist groß. Ich drück Pflege, er ist doch jedes Mal ein Spaß, mein bester Freund der Podcast. Und ich hör mir immer weiter, alles an, ganz egal wohin es geht, ich bleibe dran.
Ich drück Play, er ist da, jedes Mal ein Spaß.
Mein bester Freund, der Podcast, mein bester Freund, der Podcast und dich. Die beiden haben mir so viel gegeben. Ich glaub, ich schreib denen einfach mal was, auch wenn sie es wahrscheinlich niemals
lesen werden. Florentin und Stefan, ich dachte, ich schreib euch mal, ich weiss, ihr kennt mich nicht, aber ihr seid meine besten Freunde. eigentlich. Jeden habe ich ja jetzt und das muss ja auch immer gut sein, denke ich mir. An irgendeinem Punkt ist er dann auch, also reich zu haben. Du wolltest doch in See stechen und die Welt umrunden.
Florentin ist etwas Neues, also weißt du, ich bin ja dann auch, man muss ja sagen, ich habe jetzt
quasi wieder einen neuen Lebensabschnitt, sozusagen so eine neue Fokussierung in meinem Leben
vorgenommen, Florentin. Ich kann mir doch auch nicht helfen, aber ich habe eine neue Phase. Okay? Stefan. Ich habe ein neues Hobby, seit letzter Woche Mittwoch, es ist toll.
Stimmt wirklich.
Na, okay.
Es macht riesengrossen Spass und ich beschäftige mich damit jeden Tag.
Nee, ist klar.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, du.
Klar, in der Anschaffung war's teuer, aber das war einfach immer schon mein Traum und da musst du mir jetzt wirklich mal vertrauen.
Ich weiss schon, was du sagen wirst, ob dir das in ner Woche noch gefällt, doch ich weiss, das ist kein rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Also spitz deine Ohren, ich mach es dir mal vor. Ja, ja, ist ja ganz gut, aber eine Frage muss jetzt doch mal erlaubzeug spielen, das Ding habe ich auch schon wieder verkauft, aber... Seit letzter Woche Mittwoch interessiere ich mich für einen Segelschein, auch hier in Köln gibt's ja wirklich nur den Rhein, und mir ist zuletzt noch eingefallen.
Spanisch fand ich immer schon ganz toll, mi llamo Stefan, yo hablo espanol, und jetzt pass gut auf. Ich hab Meditieren für mich entdeckt, und ich hab's wirklich drauf. Ja, äh, nicht schlecht, aber eine Frage habe ich immer noch. Ist das wieder nur ne Phase und übermorgen schon vorbei? Ist das wieder nur ne Phase, wie lange bleibt er dabei? Ist das wieder nur ne Phase und totale Spinnerei? Ist das wieder nur ne Phase, wie lange bleibst du dabei? Oder ist das, was sie sagen, wahr, wo vorlaufe ich eigentlich davon, was mache ich, wenn der Podcast auch nur ne Phase war?
Hab ich ne Form von ADH-Moment, singen macht voll Spaß. Eines Tages singe ich in einem Musical den Hauptpaar, das wär toll, oh yeah. Auf dem Broadway und dem Western tanze ich über alle Bühnen,
bin ein Star und mein Gesicht erstrahlt im Lampenlicht.
Oh, ich seh's schon vor mir, dann hält mich nichts mehr hier.
Ey, ohne Witz jetzt, ich glaub da wirklich dran. Ich glaub, ich hab endlich gefunden, was ich wirklich sein will. Ich werde Musicalsänger Florentin. Das wollte ich eh immer schon werden. Das ist es jetzt. Vergiss alles andere, Schlagzeug spielen, Segelboot fahren, meditieren, das waren nur Phasen. Aber Musical, das ist mein Leben. Ist das wieder nur ne Phase? Auf keinen Fall, denn dieses Mal bleib ich wirklich voll dabei. Ist das wieder nur ne Phase? Nein, ich glaube fest daran, die Tickets sind gebucht, yeah, yeah. Wie lange bleib ich, wie lange bleib ich, wie lange bleib ich dabei? Ist das wieder nur ne Phase? Das Ufo war nur ein Sprungbrett für meine Broadway-Karriere. Ist das wieder nur ne Phase? Flupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflupflup Die! Ähm, okay, dann, ähm, was soll ich jetzt machen, ähm, haben wir Amantanafrika vielleicht? Ähm, Bienen. Ähm, äh, ist euch schon mal aufgefallen, dass Bienen irgendwie total orientierungslos durch die Gegend fliegen, so irgendwie so ein bisschen so, äh, wo, wo war die Blume nochmal gerade? Ich hab doch gerade noch einen Hibiskus gesehen, irgendwie so, als hätten sie ihr geparktes Auto.
Was hörst du da eigentlich immer? Hm? Was hast du gesagt, Oma?
Was du da eigentlich immer hörst. Das? Ach so, das ist ein Podcast.
Ein was? Podk? Was soll das denn sein?
Pass auf, Oma, ich erkläre dir, was ein Podcast ist. Dafür müssen wir aber, glaube ich, ein bisschen zurückgehen.
Eigentlich fing alles an mit Olli Schulz und Jan Böhmermann, die oft erhielten sich an einem stinknormalen Sonntag in Deutschland. Die beiden kamen vom Radio, da lief es plötzlich
nicht mehr so, dann wurde auch sanft und sorgfältig, der Dauerbrenner fest und flauschig, die Server liefen mächtig heiß, Podcasts waren der neue Scheiss und vor allem männlich und weiss. Aber dann kamen immer neue Stars, Sex vergnügen, Radio Nucula,
herrngedeckt mit Ariana und Laura.
Irgendwann kam Spotify und hatte sehr viel Geld dabei, Canucola, herrngedeckt mit Ariana und Laura.
Irgendwann kam Spotify und hatte sehr viel Geld dabei,
seitdem gibt es fest und flauschig, jede Woche zweimal glaub ich,
heut kriegst du was für jeden Geschmack, und damit mein ich gemischtes Hack.
Die ziehen an allen vorbei, das ist die kurze Geschichte des Podcasts. Also ist das sowas wie ein Tagebau? Ähm, nein, nicht ganz. Es ist das Medium unserer Zeit für Reportagen, Geschichten und Gelaber. Und leider kann sich wirklich keiner davor wehren, es immer wieder irgendwelchen Leuten zu erklären.
Aber mach nichts, ich tu das gern. Es ist so wie ne Radiosendung, nur im Internet. Ich hab's immer noch nicht richtig verstanden. Warum müssen Sie überhaupt wissen, was ein Podcast ist?
Ach so, Herr Buckelberg, als Ihr Steuerberater muss ich wirklich wissen, was Sie da machen.
Okay, dann ganz von vorn.
Der Name kommt vom iPod her, den gibt es jetzt schon lang nicht mehr.
Apple fügte Podcast 2005 auf iTunes ein. Der erste wirklich grosse Hit war The Ricky Gervais Show, also mit Ricky, Stephen Merchant und Carl Pilkingen dabei.
Das erste Ding in Deutschland war Tim Pridloffs Chaos Radio.
Und nun zur Produktion. Ein Podcast aufnehmen? Das geht so. Ariana, Laura?
Zwei Kondensatoren, Mikrofone, Kabel und ein Interface, ein Audioprogramm wie Garage Band oder auch Audition.
Ich seh's an ihrem Blick, sie wollen scheinbar ganz zurück zur Welt der Informatik, zu den Anfängen des Technischen.
Sophie?
Gern, also ganz am Anfang noch lange vor Fest und Flauschig hat Tristan Louie das technische Konzept entwickelt, bevor dann der erste Podcast überhaupt von Dave Weiner umgesetzt wurde, kurz danach auch vom ehemaligen MTV-Moderator Adam Curry und das alles mit einer Technologie, die bis heute denkbar einfach geblieben ist, Eddie. Man erstellt ein MP3-File, bindet das auf einem RSX-Beat ein, wo es von einem Podcatcher abgerufen bzw. heruntergeladen wird.
Das ist die technische Geschichte des Podcamps.
Also ist das wie so ein Vlog?
Oh nein! Chargengeschichten und Gelaber und leider kann sich wirklich keiner davor wehren, es immer wieder irgendwelchen Leuten zu erklären.
Aber macht nichts, ich tu das gern. Es ist so wie im ersten Refrain bereits erwähnt, so wie eine Radiosendung nur im Internet. Mittlerweile macht doch jeder so'n Podcast. Oh nein, die Gagkeepers! Was soll denn dieser Hype? Die sind genauso nervig wie die Leute, die nicht wissen, was Podcasts sind. Mittlerweile macht doch jeder so'n Podcast. Was soll denn dieser Hype, was genau, mittlerweile macht doch jeder so'n Podcast, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es nicht, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn dieser Hype, steht es das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was soll denn das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nie zu viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was soll denn das Problem, ist das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nicht so viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was soll denn das Problem, ist das Problem, was genau, es kann doch nicht so viele Podcasts geben, was soll denn das Problem, was soll denn das Problem Weile noch nie, die sich einen Podcast geben? Hey, hey Leute! Julia, oh zum Glück bist du da. Ganz ruhig, ihr beschwert euch doch auch nicht, dass es zu viele Bücher gibt.
Akzeptiert halt mal ein neues Medium.
Podcasts sind ne leere Leinwand, die man neu bemalen kann.
Man kann's nicht leicht erklären, vielleicht ist das das Gute dran.
Podcasts sind kein bloser Hype, sie sind älter als ihr es seid. so und jetzt kommt alle mal her zu mir. Es ist das Medium unserer Wahl für unsere Wünsche, Gefühle und Träume, wir unterhalten euch mit Quatsch und Expertise. Damit es weitergeht, braucht es diese Räume, Podcasts sind unser Zuhause. Im. Es ist das Medium unserer Wahl für unsere Wünsche, Gefühle und Träume. Wir unterhalten euch mit Quatsch und Expertise im Internet. Damit es weitergeht, braucht es diese Räume.
Alle Podcasts sind unser Zuhause Im Internet
Wodkas sind unser Zuhause
Im Internet
Im Internet Sonnett! Ich bin jetzt jedenfalls wieder hier in Köln und wollte fragen, ob wir morgen aufnehmen können, so um zehn im Studio, seit sieben langen Jahren läuft das so. Ich setz mich an den Tisch und steck das Mikrokabel ein, klapp den Rechner auf und Florentin kommt rein, ich sag Hallo. Jede Woche Dienstag um elf im Studio, zwei hundertachtzig Folgen läuft das so. Ich komm in den Raum und Ja, also eigentlich haben wir zehn gesagt. Er sitzt mir gegenüber, ich weiss gar nicht, wer wirklich ist.
Seit Jahren Ufo, Brüder, ich kenn den Titzler, aber Stefan nicht. Hinter dem Mikrofon, ich sitze hier und du da, hinter dem Mikrofon sind wir uns niemals nah. Wir reden und reden, aber sagen uns nichts, ich seh nicht mal dein Gesicht hinter dem Mikrofon. Ich frag ihn was Privates, das mache ich eigentlich nie, doch alles, was dann kommt, ist Ironie. Auf der Tour bekommen wir gemeinsam den Applaus, doch nach der Show gehen wir allein nach Haus. Hat er eine Freundin, wo wohnt er und was hört er für Musik? Wir wissen nichts übereinander, ich hoffe so sehr, er ist kein Antisemit.
Hinter dem Mikrofon hat alles angefangen,
hinter dem Mikrofon sind wir schon viel zu lang.
Wir reden und reden, aber sagen uns nichts. Ich seh nicht mal dein Gesicht. In deinem Meer wohlfassend. Vielleicht ist unsere Zeit gekommen,
an den Deutschen Podcastpreis gewonnen. Was bleibt uns denn noch? Kann ich ganz auf Musical konzentrieren? Dann kann ich mehr für Warcraft 3 trainieren, für wen machen wir das noch? Ich dachte, ich schreib euch mal, ich weiss, ihr kennt mich nicht, aber ihr seid meine besten Freunde, ihr bringt mich zum Lachen, ohne euch wär ich allein. Bitte hört niemals auf, eure Isabel Klein. Ich lese ihre Nachricht und plötzlich wird mir klar, alles was mir wichtig ist, das liegt im Grunde da hinter dem Mikrofon, ihr seid, was uns noch hier hält. Hinter dem Mikrofon liegt eine ganze Welt. Ich glaube, wenn man mehr als 250 Folgen zusammen aufnimmt, dann kennt man sich, glaube ich, doch ganz gut.
Ja, das stimmt. Und noch was, Podcasten ist keine Phase, du bist Podcaster.
Und vielleicht sind deine Phasen ja sogar gut für den Podcast.
Ich meine, wer sagt denn, dass ein Podcast kein Musical sein kann? Blick gelöst bekommen. Das war ganz schön knapp, stellt euch nur mal vor, mit Tränen
in den Augen vor dem tanzenden Chor. Danke Isabel, ohne dich wären wir nicht hier, dass wir weitermachen liegt an Fans wie dir. Danke, dass ihr lacht, wir leben davon, und sonst gibt es ja noch Patreon. Wir heben ab bis nächste Woche, da gibt es schon die nächste Folge, es geht immer weiter, denn wir hören so schnell nicht auf.
Wir heben ab bis nächsten Samstag mit meinem Stoffe, wenn die mich nicht so gern mag. Wir wollen unser Leben lang Podcaster sein. Wir heben ab! So viel schon erlebt, in all den ganzen Jahren, Webseite gelöscht, Antenne, Askerbahn, in der Pufopedia ist alles archiviert, die Telegram-Gruppe hat sich radikalisiert. Wie C, Schwan und Thais, Florentin und Joyce, fast H-100 Folgen von euren Boys. Es war die beste Zeit, mehr aber auch nicht, das Ufo kriegt grünes Licht. Wir heben ab bis nächste Woche, da gibt es schon die nächste Folge. Es geht immer weiter, denn wir hören so schnell nicht auf. Wir heben ab, ready for take off, unsere Fans sind unser Treibstoff, wir lassen euch mit eurem Alltag nicht allein. Wir heben ab! Eklatlich wie ich mich auf jede Folge freue, dafür bleib ich euch wie immer. Was sollen wir jetzt machen, wenn sie weg ist, dann können wir es auch gleich lassen. Weisst du was, ich mach das nicht für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, jedenfalls nicht nur, sollen die doch alle zu gemischtes Hack gehen, nein, ich mach's wegen dir, es macht mir unglaublich viel Spaß, jede Woche mit dir kommen in die ja und mir auch und weisst du was, es gibt niemanden, mit dem ich das lieber machen würde als mit dir.
Komm her. mehr. Oder Pandemie, wir machen immer weiter, aufhören werden wir nie.
You and me und patreon.com das ist p-h-t-r-e-o-n.com slash das Podcast UFO Wir heben ab bis nächste Woche, dann gibt es schon die nächste Folge, es geht immer weiter, denn wir hören so schnell nicht auf.
Wir heben ab bis nächste Woche, dann kommt wieder eine normale Folge, es geht, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, unsere Fans sind unser Treibstoff, wir lassen euch mit eurem Alltag nicht allein. Wir heben ab, wir heben ab, wir heben ab. Vorher die Lohnschlepper hinter dem Mikrofon. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,